welcome to this video yeah playing sofia
Loren yeah probably not got a name oh
that's a brand new account let's see ya
so we do check but you never know could
be anything anybody let's see you get
this sharp line here of the bogo before
here okay yeah of course that sets also
move I think I my recommendation is to
play D 5c 595 i'm not mistaken always
not really not really it's not advancing
okay there are many many possible setups
can go see 5 or a 5 both does make some
sense okay I can start with this move
trying to provoke him in a way to move
the bishop you have like Miss Bishop d3
or something that only then c5 yeah not
sure if it's really anything special but
let's do it
yeah those new accounts always difficult
to to to evaluate yeah they only have
very little games played and it could be
they just had a good run and are weaker
or it could also be that they are much
much stronger and the severely
underrated it's a everything is possible
okay so this doesn't look that bad got a
decent development only wonder nights
here or to see 6 i'm not sure 96 kind of
gains a tempo but the night is not great
on c6 and here maybe have 95 in the
right moment in general this is a fairly
symmetrical position quite threat
obviously so it's certainly about equal
I'm sure that Bishop c4 was was so
helpful for him in the Queen on d5 I
mean it was it looked active but it's
not that I wasn't threatening anything
and hmm yeah this is
yeah I don't have anything great yeah
like 95 queen age five that's not
leading to anything it's equal average
not nothing more
now maybe maybe that's it's actually
quite interesting I mean interesting is
the wrong word it is just very equal but
this this might help might be helpful
that I can actually trade those bishops
yeah it is totally totally nothing
happening here but maybe this is still
precise so that i get rid of this
bishops it could be could be a point at
one point is that i can then easily put
the rukon be aid and things like that
knight on f6 is always protecting d7 as
a possible invasion square and i don't
really want I want to see thinking about
really another move I mean the move yeah
besides taking didn't didn't really I
didn't really see one okay I want a rook
c8 maybe try to be a bit annoying rook
c7 I know this weekend stir the back
rank don't want to do that okay let's
tat skiff let's take this move give me
some some lift for the king
so very equal ish of course so Roxy's
744 look for the doubling the only very
slight idea that as here's something if
Brooks get traded yeah like this I go
here going to trade then I have roots
III this is the only little weakness and
why it's camp I mean really nothing
serious but the only little thing that I
can can see yeah he's very busy trading
things 90s or here may be there that's
interesting Bishop g5 I should be five
rook t2 i was thinking briefly if this
is an imbalance that i should create is
it or not i'm trying that I'm just
trying that it could be a wrong decision
definitely I'm normally you would prefer
to prefer the bishop but what I do have
sorry what I do have here is I have an
active rook and this is really counting
for something plus there is this h5 g4
idea this idea
so deform push push push push Maya
that's not easy okay it's going there is
there some way for me to activate Knight
to f3 this kind of thing or activate the
night night g-night h7 ok I probably
need the King anyway like here and 495
yeah 95 h3 actually ok so if I get the
check it's not really going to work chat
so i have to do this take prateik with
the night so there should be a time
morning
hmm this should be a diz a very annoying
move hmm check now yes that anywhere
become a 95 yeah i got i wanted a fight
i got it but it's not really great if I
if I have to the check maybe a way I
should have checked first wish I had the
time Bart if the bloody time
check check check check black what it's
on time yeah whatever yeah try to fight
from this very equal position and Jim I
don't know I think I just I just meet
some some inaccurate moves from a pretty
decent position the active ruckus is
certainly worth something but it's a
matter of being really really precise
IAM and i didn't have this precision the
big issue really is rugby 7 i'd be sure
bae played that was very strong check
check
maybe I'm king of 65 m maybe that one
oops sorry I went GM check yeah maybe I
should really play this this in a bit
more active wave at the apron this
wasn't their way to play it without
giving him this counter play really
wonder
now the computer wants to play this move
yeah this is strong this is strong the
bishop won't be seven assists well the
bishop would be seven means you cannot
play rugby seven and where is where are
you going yeah if you go click back here
I have this move actually check and it's
a very Jewish but when I when it gets
get to the point when I got she got the
a pawn that sets it's already very
tricky even if the computer says it's a
draw and so on with the a hornet some it
gets very problematic the combs give
comp gives me a draw for a very long
time but it's definitely not what I
wanted to hear you could have taken G
for a couple times but he blundered
nothing but ok wins on time very
difficult stuff I played that well not a
bad player of the slip try to squeeze
something out of this and well it didn't
it didn't it didn't really materialize
yeah I don't know I can also take me
this is what I should have tried I mean
ok it's equal I know and so on but maybe
this kind of thing is a bit more
interesting but slightly very slightly
more active well it's very dry ok well
thanks for watching